BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
ADDY OSMANI: Hi, there.
And welcome to this special
episode of "Chrome Developer's
Live." I'm Addy Osmani.
And with me is special guest
Seth Ladd, developer
[? outfit ?]
for Chrome focusing on
areas like Dart.
Hi, Seth.
SETH LADD: Hey, Addy.
Thanks for having me.
ADDY OSMANI: Not at all.
So, Seth, today I'm going to be
grilling you about Dart and
trying to find out some more
information about it.
Are you ready?
SETH LADD: I am ready.
I've been preparing
all weekend.
Let's do this.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
All right, so let's
set the stage.
Over the past few years there's
been quite an increase
in the number of
compile-to-JavaScript
languages, like CoffeeScript,
and alternatives to JavaScript
that have been coming
up on the scene.
Now, some of them
including some
rather interesting features.
And it's been interesting to see
sort of how they compare
and how they differ to
JavaScript and what's
available right now.
So Dart's been around for,
I guess, about a year?
SETH LADD: Yeah, we publicly
launched last October.
So it's been just
about a year.
ADDY OSMANI: Just about
a year, excellent.
I think the first time I
remember hearing about it was
on Hacker News.
And as a JavaScript developer at
the time there was quite a
lot of confusion about what it
was trying to target, what it
was going to try doing
differently than JavaScript,
whether it included additional
tools that would help
developers with creating
applications.
And some of the messaging around
it suggested that it
was trying to solve problems
that not only could JavaScript
at the time not do, but that
the language couldn't be
evolved to do those
things either.
So let's set the record
straight.
What is Dart?
And is it trying to replace
JavaScript?
SETH LADD: Great question.
It is not trying to replace
JavaScript.
Dart is a fresh approach, an
innovation if you will, to
appeal to the broad set of
developers that have a
different set of expectations.
And one of our beliefs on the
Dart project is you shouldn't
have to have 15 years of
hardcore endemic web
development experience to build
the kind of fantastic,
amazing apps that users expect,
want, and need today.
And so we want to make it easier
for developers with
other experiences like Java,
and C#, and C++, and
ActionScript to be able to
approach web development and
have the same great experience
that the hard core web
developers with those tremendous
amount of years of
experience have.
So that we can help everyone
build for what's probably the
most ubiquitous and powerful
platform out there, the web.
ADDY OSMANI: So it almost sounds
like you're trying to
lower the barrier of entry for
people coming from other
programming languages.
And not necessarily just
targeting people who already
have a good level of experience
with JavaScript.
SETH LADD: Yeah, I think
that's fair to say.
I mean, there's a lot of people,
a lot of JavaScript
developers and many of them
are very experienced.
And part of that's the power
of the language, part of
that's the platform.
And they're doing great.
They're obviously already
launching
really fantastic apps.
I mean, there's some great
apps out there.
Google+, Google Apps,
Facebook.
These are large apps built
with the current web
technologies.
But then there's a whole other
set of developers out there
that we also want to help to
bring over onto the web.
And they've got a certain set
of expectations around the
language, there's an expectation
on the tooling and
development cycles and the use
of things like patterns and
practices that they've
grown up with.
And so if we can give them that
experience and hopefully
even do better than what they
expect then that just means
more developers are now building
for the web and
that's a good thing.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
That seems fair enough.
So I'm sure you know there are
a lot of developers that love
JavaScript.
It's in many places considered
the most popular programming
language at the moment at least
for the web, definitely.
With so many active contributors
sort of working
on JavaScript engines V8,
Chakra, SpiderMonkey,
JavaScript seems to have
a really great
future ahead of it.
Some developers would wonder
why not try improving
JavaScript the language and the
ecosystem around it with
respect to tooling rather than
say creating a brand new
language and a whole other
type of workflow.
What's your response to that?
SETH LADD: Yeah, that's
a good question.
It's important to understand
that this is not
an either, or world.
This is an and world.
And if we can give more options
and help more people
come to the web, that's good.
And let's remember that Google
itself specifically continues
to invest in TC39, which is the
spec group working on the
future of JavaScript.
We still have very awesome
engineers in
Munich working on V8.
We've got just such an awesome
investment in Chrome and the
open web and specifically
JavaScript today.
Another good example there
would be our work in Web
Components.
So you know, we're able to, I
think, look at this problem of
how do you get bigger, better,
more complex, higher
performance apps on the web
from two different angles?
And we believe in a world where
both of these things
actually exist.
And I feel personally that as
long as we continue to invest
in the JavaScript, V8, TC39
route and we continue to
invest in the Dart, Dart VM,
Dart Editor route as well
we're just reaching an even
broader audience.
And that's good.
I think frankly we're lucky to
be able to work from both
angles to the same problem.
ADDY OSMANI: Definitely.
Yeah So you mentioned complex
apps and large scale apps in
your last response.
Is Dart sort of optimized to
be used in those scenarios
where you're building something
that's just very,
very nontrivial?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
I think if you need to do some
simple form validation
JavaScript's fantastic
for that.
I mean it's got functions,
top level functions.
You don't need to wrap
things in classes.
So for the super simple
stuff, not a problem.
And for some developers
they can scale up.
But when we talk about things
like 10,000 lines, 100,000
lines of code, which is not
unusual for these bigger, more
complex apps, for instance they
take advantage of all of
the amazing HTML5 features,
like WebGL for hardware
accelerated 3D and File System
API and WebRTC for microphones
and cameras.
And then when you start thinking
about things like
transient networking
connectivity and how do you
write an offline app, I mean,
the list goes on and on.
When you add all of these things
together into the same
app the lines of code grow.
And we've seen that you often
need a little bit more
structure in your language and
a little bit more power in
your tools and that's really
where Dart's sweet spot is.
We're really targeting those
multi-multi-thousand line
programs, when you have more
than 10 developers working
together that need to
collaborate more
friction-free, if you will.
And that's the kind of
experience that we think Dart
is really good at.
ADDY OSMANI: So you're talking
about applications with very
large teams.
They're complex, perhaps there
are hundreds of thousands of
lines of code, a huge number
of modules to them.
What specifically in Dart helps
me with those type of
applications versus just using
JavaScript in a modern stack
composed of RequireJS
and what have you?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
No, that's a great question.
So there's a lot in Dart
that is going to help
people scale up.
And so part of what we usually
talk about is scaling from the
small set of functions and maybe
just one class all the
way up to the 10,000, 100,000
line programs out there.
And Dart really allows you to
do that through its use of
optional types and top
level functions.
So one myth we probably want to
debunk is that in Dart it's
not all about just
classes, right?
You don't have to kind of
swallow that whole pill of all
these language features
just to use Dart.
You can start with just a
simple set of functions.
You don't have to use any
of those optional types.
And this is what makes
the web development
so fantastic, right?
It's very iterative.
You can start with the seed of
an idea, hit reload that acts
as your compiler, and
test out your ideas.
Grow over time.
Re-factor to add in more
features, et cetera.
That's that scaling story that
we often talk about.
And that's one of the main use
cases we want to make really
fantastic with Dart.
Specifically I think I can show
you some of these things
in action by going over
to our Dart Editor.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah,
that'd be great.
SETH LADD: So I'm going to
share my screen here.
So do you see this all right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
Yeah, I can see that fine.
SETH LADD: Fantastic.
So this is our Dart Editor.
And I'm just going to show just
a few set of features
here to answer your question.
What does Dart do in its tools
specifically to help people
write larger apps?
Well, a lot of it's about the
feedback of the Editor and the
structure of the language.
So what you're looking at here
is a very, very simple
application.
But I'm going to show
a few things.
One you can probably see a bunch
of red underlines, which
the Editor is telling us--
analysis, hey, there's
an error.
So feature number one that I
love to show is the immediate
feedback you get
from the tools.
You don't have to run the app
to know where there are
problems or where there
might be problems.
And so you can fix more in the
development cycle, less
during, say, the unit
test or the user
acceptance testing level.
So let's go ahead and resolve
some of these errors.
Well, feature number two of the
Dart platform that helps
developers scale up to larger
apps is our package manager.
Here it is.
We're pulling in three
different packages.
You can tell due to the package
colon syntax here.
And packages are similar to
the npm node packages or
RubyGems packages.
They're a way for you to package
up and distribute
bundles of functionalities so
that other developers out
there can use it.
And every time you
reuse code that's
code you're not writing.
And that helps people
scale up.
So let's go ahead and run a
Pub, which is our package
manager which you can do
straight from the Editor.
Now, it's important to remember
you can do almost all
of this stuff in the command
line as well.
Let's go ahead and
run Pub install.
Whoops, wrong directory.
And that's going to read
our Dependencies file.
Go out onto the net, pull down
these packages for us.
And, boom.
The Editor then re-analyzes
everything.
You can see the red
lines go away.
So again, that instant feedback
is really fantastic.
The other thing you can do is
just run these apps straight
from the editor.
So a really fantastic edit,
run, slash debug cycle is
really, really important when
you scale up your apps.
So let's go ahead
and run here.
And sure enough my app is
running and I get cat pics.
So this is probably the
best thing ever you're
going to see all day.
So I'm going to let this sink
in for a second, which you
probably can't see.
Let me go ahead and share
the whole desktop here.
Desktop.
Sorry about that.
There we go.
Awesome.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome.
SETH LADD: OK.
So cat pic.
So what we're seeing here,
though, is three separate
packages all working together.
So that's another feature
of Dart that helps
people scale up.
Because we've baked into the
language the structure.
Things like classes, and
libraries, and interfaces, and
optional static types.
At the language level you're
now able to build upon
frameworks and widgets that
other third party
developers can build.
And you don't have
to do this at the
high-level framework level.
We're doing it at the
language level.
So the frame itself
is from a package.
The widget itself is
from a package.
And the cat pic itself
is from a package.
One other thing I want
to show from our
Editor experience here--
let me just shut off my,
there we go, email--
is the integrated debugging
experience.
And so this is another really
important thing.
As you scale up your apps you
of course are going to run
into some issues or problems.
And how do you debug?
How do you set breakpoints?
How do you step through
the code?
Now, of course Chrome and
Firefox and others have really
fantastic developer tools.
And many developers have an
expectation around doing that
in their editors.
So for instance, we are going
to set a breakpoint directly
in our Editor.
We're going to run
this app again.
And what has happened is it
fires this app in Dartium, our
build of Chromium with the Dart
VM, but it fires off the
breakpoint inside the Editor.
And you can see here I'm able,
hopefully you guys can see, is
I'm able to step through my
application actually using the
embedded debugger.
Now, of course, we can do that
in the DevTools as well.
[? Being ?] able to sit in the
Editor with all the fantastic
static analysis and warnings and
errors and other features
of the Editor, like code
completion, and be able to
debug at the same time is a
really great experience,
especially when you
try to scale up to
10,000 lines of code.
So one other thing I'm going to
show you here, a last thing
I'm going to show you about
some of the features that
allows us to scale up is
that code completion
I was talking about.
So let's go ahead and create
an Awesome class here.
And "do cool stuff" is the
method I'm going to create.
And we're just going to simply
say print, let's
see, Dart is fun.
OK.
Well, when you're able to have a
more structured language and
when you add things like
optional static types and in
Editor, that can do type
influencing and type
propagation, you can do some
really cool things, like code
completion.
And this is really important
when you try to walk yourself
through APIs that you're
unfamiliar with.
And this happens all the time
when you're talking about
10,000, 100,000 lines of code.
You're going to run into
libraries, and classes, and
packages that you yourself
didn't write.
And the guy that wrote that
might literally be in another
time zone, et cetera.
So how do you explore your
program when you don't know
much about it?
Well, code completion here
helps you do that.
You can see here
that the editor
pops up his best guesses.
And in this case he actually,
I think, got it perfectly
right about what I can call on
this Awesome class here.
I can "do cool stuff." And then
go ahead and get that
code completion.
And, of course, if I type
in something incorrect--
ADDY OSMANI: Yup.
SETH LADD: I get my Editor
telling me, hmm, Awesome has
no method called "slada slad."
ADDY OSMANI: I see.
SETH LADD: So that's exactly the
kind of instant feedback
that I should be getting.
And it's critically important
when I for instance am working
with such a large code
base, I can't keep it
all inside my head.
There's a lot of other features
I can probably show
but hopefully that
gives you an idea
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, yeah.
It definitely [INAUDIBLE].
SETH LADD: --of some of the
power of the language and it's
play with the Editor to
help you scale up.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
So from a developer's
perspective how much of Dart
is the language itself and
how much is the actual
tools behind it?
Because there you're using
Dart Editor, right?
SETH LADD: Yeah, yeah.
That's a good question.
Dart's much more than
a language.
I think that's important
to understand.
I almost want to use
the word platform.
I'm not exactly sure.
But it's definitely
a large project.
And the project encompasses
certainly the language, but a
set of core libraries.
So we're also providing things
like collection support for
lists, arrays, and sets.
Timer support for when you want
to fire off a callback.
Isolates, which is how we
do concurrency in VMs.
And even compile the JavaScript
as web workers.
We also have the ancillary
libraries everyone expects
like unit tests and mocks,
working with JSON, working
with dates.
And the list goes on and on.
So that's our libraries.
Certainly the Dart Editor,
which you just saw.
We also have plug-ins for
Eclipse and the JetBrains guys
who make IntelliJ and WebStorm,
a fantastic web IDE,
also have a plug-in
for Dart as well.
There's the package manager that
we just saw that allows
you to not only pull down
packages, but publish packages.
I'm also forgetting some-- oh,
and then of course the virtual
machine, which runs Dart
code natively.
And we were just doing
that Dartium.
But probably most importantly,
other than the language of
course, is our
compiler-to-JavaScript.
And this is a really
key point.
Another myth to debunk
is that Dart is not
just a Chrome thing.
We are on our third generation
compiler-to-JavaScript.
And the output is incredibly
smaller than I think what
people first saw.
And they were, rightly
so, shocked when
they first saw it.
But our third generation--
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, I mean
anytime you see sort of code
that's being compiled or
generated by some other tool
often it's not very pretty.
SETH LADD: Right.
ADDY OSMANI: What's
the code like that
Dart-to-JS actually generates?
SETH LADD: Well,
let's do that.
And I'll just pull
up the Editor.
Because you can do that
in the Editor.
And so yes.
To complete the last major
component of the Dart project
is the compiler to JavaScript.
So let's go ahead
and do that now.
Because Dart, at its core, must
run across the modern web
and run in browsers like
IE9 and above,
Firefox, Safari, Chrome.
So if you build Dart apps they
should work in the modern web.
So your question was about
compiling JavaScript.
So let's do that now.
So we're going to take the same
app, the cat pics app,
and let's run it in
another browser.
So if I right click here and
I say run as JavaScript the
first thing it's going to do
is run Dart-to-JS, compile
this whole thing
to JavaScript.
Now it also performs this
technique called tree shaking,
which is really, really cool.
What tree shaking does--
a-ha, here's our--
now this is Chrome.
And I can prove this, how
can I prove this?
I can prove it by this.
About version.
Right, so straight up
Chrome, Chrome 22.
This does not have the Dart
Virtual Machine in it.
So what's happening here?
Well, we've compiled
the JavaScript.
So this is running in the
JavaScript version.
But we've got this fantastic
feature called Source Maps.
And Source Maps allow us to--
let me just reload this.
Whoop, this isn't what
I want here.
So here is our compiled
JavaScript.
This is your first question.
I'm going answer this.
There's no minification
happening right now.
That's a separate step
you can run.
You can also run this through
Closure Compiler as well to
get a smaller output if
that's what you like.
But the code is fairly
readable.
And so we think that there's
secondary or tertiary steps
that we can process this
JavaScript code to get even
smaller concatenate and
minified output.
But this is the raw output.
I can go into some of
the things here.
All Dart code runs
in an isolate.
ADDY OSMANI: OK.
SETH LADD: And all that simply
means is that we have this
safer concurrency model than
shared state thread.
So that's why you might see
this isolate word here.
So yeah.
So that works.
But I was hoping to show the
Source Maps, which doesn't
seem to be running right now.
So we're going to have
to come back to that.
But Source Maps is
a fantastic--
oh, you know what?
Let me just--
help me out here.
There's a way to get--
turn on Source Maps
here, right?
ADDY OSMANI: There should be if
you click on Enable Source
Maps, yeah.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
Let me reload this.
Thank you.
OK.
Open this up.
A-ha!
Great.
Good I wanted to show this.
So this was actually good.
Because I showed you the
compiled JavaScript.
So it's fairly readable.
But what most people want to
do is actually work in the
source language.
So if you write CoffeeScript,
you want to debug in
CoffeeScript.
If you want to write Dart, you
want to debug in Dart.
And so thanks to our Source
Maps, which maps the original
code over to the compiled
JavaScript.
Now, the Developer Tools know
about this mapping file.
So you can see now in our
DevTools I'm able to click on
the scripts and it loads up
the actual Dart code.
Now, remember this is regular
Chrome without the Dart VM.
But it's able to, through the
mapping file, actually say, oh
hey, I'm going to hide that
compiled JavaScript code.
I'm going to show you the
original code that you wrote.
And I can even set breakpoints
inside the original code.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
SETH LADD: So now if I
reload here, boom.
It actually stops right at the
breakpoint from the original
Dart code even though this is
all being mapped back to the
compiled JavaScript.
So yes, the compiled JavaScript
is important.
It should be fairly readable.
But thanks to Source Maps you're
probably not going to
be looking at the compiled
JavaScript that often.
And certainly most modern web
developers minify, and
obfuscate, and concatenate
further making the compiled
output just kind of like the
output of an EXE that you're
C++ compiler would generate.
You don't really look at that.
And you want to debug it at a
much more user friendly level.
And we can do that now.
ADDY OSMANI: Very cool.
SETH LADD: That's pretty cool.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, I
love Source Maps.
If you could go back to that
window for a moment, I'm not
sure if that's been closed up.
SETH LADD: Oh, the
browswer one?
ADDY OSMANI: I had a question
about the source.
So I was just wondering in that
source view of sort of
what was generated how much of
that code was sort of the
application itself and how much
of it was sort of Dart
specific, Runtime, or Utilities,
and other stuff?
SETH LADD: That's a
great question.
I'll share this here and
I'll just pull it up
in the Editor itself.
That might be a little bit
easier for us to look at.
So you're probably [INAUDIBLE]
lines of things like jQuery,
which you download a 30K kind
of boilerplate code, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Oh, Seth?
We can't see your window
at the moment.
Just a second.
SETH LADD: You might
have to click the--
can you see that?
ADDY OSMANI: Uh, no.
It still seems to be gone.
We're going to have a technician
look at that.
Could you talk us through
roughly how much of what we
saw was sort of Runtime versus
actual app [INAUDIBLE]?
SETH LADD: Yeah, certainly.
So thanks to our Dart-to-JS
compiler's technique called
tree shaking it worked really
hard to eliminate the unused
bits of code, which is
really important.
It's interesting when you go to
any JavaScript library the
main marketing bullet point
is how small they are.
Which is important, obviously,
for many reasons.
Network, bandwidth, latency,
et cetera.
But as a developer I want to
know, does the library do
something useful, right?
Does it actually help me?
Not how small it is.
Because I want the linker step
or the compiler step to prune
everything out for me.
So the code that you see
compiled to JavaScript is
pretty close to the minimal set
of code required just for
that application.
ADDY OSMANI: OK.
SETH LADD: There's not a lot of
boilerplate, if you will.
Very, very little bits of it.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
A question that we got through
was developers were,
obviously, [INAUDIBLE].
So TypeScript was announced
in the past week.
There's a lot of interest
around it.
A natural thing for developers
to want to do is
compare Type with Dart.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: Could you talk
a little bit about the
differences?
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
So we were very happy to
see TypeScript get
launched and announced.
This is great.
It's another company saying,
hey, there's another way to
write larger scaled applications
out there and add
it with a great tooling story,
like Visual Studio has for
TypeScript, is a validation
of what we're trying to
do over with Dart.
So there are some
similarities.
For instance, the optional
static typing.
Both languages allow you
to add static type
annotations, or not.
Up to you.
Both are building up a great
Editor story as well.
TypeScript had Visual Studio.
Dart runs in the Editor or
Eclipse, or IntelliJ.
ADDY OSMANI: OK.
SETH LADD: But then there's
also some--
ADDY OSMANI: I'm think we're
going to just stop for a very
quick minute.
We're going to reload
up just to see if we
can get your feedback.
Say again?
We're going to stop
for just a second.
We're going to reload just to
see it we can get your video
input back.
We're good to go.
Excellent.
SETH LADD: OK, cool.
ADDY OSMANI: So feel free
to continue, Seth.
SETH LADD: OK, awesome.
Can you hear me now?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, yes we can.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
But there are some differences
in the language design.
TypeScript, as far as I can
tell, keeps the semantics of
JavaScript.
And Dart goes much,
much further.
So for instance, Dart's integers
are arbitrarily
scaled out integers.
JavaScript, obviously, has
only one number type.
Dart has doubles and numbers
and integers.
Another difference might include
Dart has generics.
And those generics are reified,
which means the
generic information, the
parametrized types are
codified at Runtime
and Compile-time.
TypeScript does not right
now have generics.
And I believe what they said is
when they do add generics
they will erased at Compiled
or Runtime.
So there is a difference
there.
The type annotation syntax
itself is different.
Dart uses the more familiar Java
and C versions of type
annotations where it's on
the left-hand side.
And TypeScript uses on
the right-hand side.
I think familiar to, I
believe, ActionScript
developers.
And there's something other
differences, too.
I think the Dart project
goes a lot further.
For instance, we have this
concept of isolates for shared
nothing concurrency.
I assume that TypeScript, again,
keeping with JavaScript
semantics, runs at a single
thread and uses things like
web workers to get concurrency
there.
Another kind of more subtle but
interesting point is Dart,
you're able to downcast due
to its type system.
And in TypeScript there's
no implicit downcasting.
But in a similarity both
languages have a lexical this,
which is a fantastic addition.
And all new modern languages
have lexical this.
But in general they're both
trying to attack the same
problem, how do we enable
developers to build more
larger complex apps for
the modern web.
And so I think that's good.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, I think
we're going to see a lot
coming out of TypeScript, Dart,
and other solutions as
people start to play
with it more.
Going back to the idea of Dart
being sort of slightly more
full stack, if you will, one
question we got in over
moderator was how well
does it work with
say, JavaScript libraries?
People are using a ton of
MVC frameworks, utility
libraries, and so on.
If you're using Dart do you
have to be using modules
written in Dart lang?
Or can you actually use other
JavaScript libraries with it?
How does that work?
SETH LADD: That's a great
question we recently launched
our synchronous JavaScript
interop capability that allows
you to use existing JavaScript
libraries in your Dart
application.
Now, transparent as something
like TypeScript which is just
a new syntax on the
same semantics.
But it does give you very, very
close to transparently
using these libraries.
So for instance, you can use the
more synchronous stateful
APIs, like the Twitter API, or
Google Maps API, or the Google
Visualization API, the sorts of
APIs in your Dart program.
And that's really,
really nice.
I don't believe that the use
case of jQuery is something we
are targeting with this.
JQuery is really fantastic
because it makes the DOM feel
like JavaScript.
And so a one to one translation
or a, I'm going to
use jQuery in Dart, may not be
the most effective thing.
Because Dart is not
JavaScript.
And so some of the usage
paradigms or just simply
features of the API may not
work perfectly correctly.
The good news is we have our own
version a jQuery, if you
will, a better DOM that gets
bundled with Dart called Dart
colon HTML, that's
the library.
And it has a lot of jQuery-isms
in there.
And it will get better there.
So I think for this synchronous
stateful type APIs
that many JavaScript libraries
have you'll be able to use
those in your Dart code.
And we have a lot of demos
of that already
on our GitHub account.
ADDY OSMANI: So if I wanted to
use something like AngularJS
or Backbone I could actually
use that with Dart.
SETH LADD: I don't think
Angular JS, actually.
Because I think that, again, is
very ingrained in some of
the features of JavaScript, like
its eval functionality.
So it remains to be seen how
good of a programming
experience it might
be to integrate
Angular in with Dart.
But I do believe that other
frameworks, or other stateful
synchronous libraries out there,
like Google Maps API or
the Facebook API, those
things are going to be
very easy to use.
And we have demos of
some of those.
So I'd be interested to see
what happens if you try to
actually use Backbone with
Dart via our JS interop.
But what I suspect is that
that's a little bit too low
level to be a really fantastic
experience.
But we've already seen a
bunch of MVC frameworks
launched for Dart.
And we have open source work
ongoing right now for our web
components plus Dart work, which
we are putting a lot of
resources behind to be the bet
we're placing on how to build
a modern web app.
So look for more on that soon.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
Yeah, I was about to say my
perception based on what you
described was that rather than
just taking the existing
libraries it's probably more the
case that perhaps you take
existing patterns that you're
used to and try to apply it to
Dart, given that it's a
different language.
But it's really great to hear
that you guys have got a great
flow for people that can use
JavaScript APIs for things
like the Facebook integration
and so on.
One question that I was quite
curious about was so whenever
you're picking a full stack
solution or a solution that
you're going to be using for a
serious application one of the
first things you think about
is maturity and has that
solution been already used to
build a platform or an app of
some sort before?
Has Dart been used to build
any large or real world
applications either at Google
or outside of it?
SETH LADD: Well, we've seen a
tremendous amount of third
party libraries already launched
for Dart which is
really fantastic for
a language that's
not even yet at 0.1.
So we're still technically
technology previewed.
And so we've seen everything
from box to deports to logging
frameworks to multiple
options for MVC.
We've even seen things like
modDart to embed the Dart VM
into Apache.
You can run Dart in Heroku.
And so we're now seeing that
infrastructure of the
community getting built up at
the library and package and
framework levels.
As far as what's happening
inside Google I don't have a
lot to comment on this
publicly now.
But I can say that there
are teams working
on it inside Google.
And as far as public apps as
well we've seen this smaller
kind of demo and feasibility
study stuff right now.
And I expect a lot more when we
have our M1 release which
is coming up soon.
And that's our first public
milestone since
the technology previewed.
And that's essentially our
statement to the world saying,
hey, the Dart language is in a
fairly stable state right now.
We've got our libraries now
in a good position to be
refactored and improved.
Now is a good time for
you to start building
your apps with it.
And so I think that tipping
point, if you will, is going
to happen very, very soon.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
So my last question.
So let's move forward in the
future, a year or two.
Web Components are hopefully in
a much more stable state.
They've been implemented across
a number of browsers.
What's the Dart story there?
Do you think that it's going
to greatly help people
building modern futuristic
apps at that point?
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
I'm glad you mentioned
Web Components.
It's something that we're
working really hard on.
And it's probably important
to talk about what are Web
Components?
Web Components adds the concept
of encapsulation to
the web platform at the lowest
web platform level.
If you think about it right now
you've got styles, you've
got behavior through JavaScript,
and you've got
structure in HTML5 all
kind of coexisting
and mashed up together.
And it's very hard
to introduce--
excuse me--
other libraries and frameworks
together without them easily
kind of get their fingers
into your code.
With Web Components you can
easily encapsulate the
structure, behavior, and styles
of these components and
then reuse them with a much
better encapsulation.
Then you could build much
better, bigger applications.
Dart allows us to bring this
technology to you today thanks
to our compiler step.
So the Web Component stuff--
excuse me, I need some water--
--that we're talking about is,
you're right, many years out
in the future.
But we can give this to you
today by writing a Web
Component with Dart then we
compile everything down to the
code that actually works in
modern browsers today.
And so, yeah, it's kind of like
working in the future
today with Dart, thanks to our
compiler-to-JavaScript.
So it's really cool.
So if you want to try Web
Components you can actually
try them today.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
OK.
I think that's our
last question.
For anybody and any JavaScript
developer, web app developer
that's watching that wants to
get started with Dart and try
it out what's the best place for
them check out and what's
the best demo application
for them to look at?
SETH LADD: Great question.
Go to dartlang.org.
Everything's on there, our docs,
our language tours, our
library tours.
But then the download of the
Editor, that's the best way to
get started.
It has the SDK.
It has the Dartium.
Thank you so much, sir.
Sorry.
Ah, here we go.
Now I can go for another hour.
But the Editor's the best
way to get started.
And when you fire up the Editor
you get a really nice
welcome screen that has all of
our demos and sample code
right there.
And so you could fire off
any of those, it makes
a copy of the code.
And you can change
the code and play
with it and play around.
So it's really, really easy.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
I believe I've also seen some
todoMVC Dart samples floating
around the web.
So people might be able
to find that.
SETH LADD: Yes, that's
a good point.
So our GitHub repository
has other samples.
It has our JavaScript
interop code.
It has our Web Components work,
which is fantastic.
And then there's a version of
todoMVC built with, I believe,
Web Components all hosted
open source at GitHub.
And so I want to remind
everybody that Dart is an open
source project.
We have external committers.
We take a lot of third
party patches.
And you could track all this
stuff, the issue tracker, the
mailing list, et cetera.
So it's really, really cool to
watch this stuff being built
up right in front of our eyes.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
I remember checking out that Web
Components demo built with
Dart and I thought it was
really, really hot.
So, yeah.
Everyone please do feel
free to check it out.
Check out the Dart website.
Let us know what you think.
And that's it for
this session.
Thank you very much to Seth Ladd
for coming and talking to
us about Dart.
It was a real eye opener getting
to find out some more
information about who it's
targeting and what it can
actually give you
out of the box.
SETH LADD: Thank you
so much, Addy.
I really appreciate it.
ADDY OSMANI: Not at all.
And that's it for
this session.
Feel free to check in with us
on Thursday where Paul Irish
and I will be introducing a
brand new show called "The
Breakpoint" which we'll be
talking about tooling in.
So that's it.
Thank you very much.